a lot of people who work at cnn really
hate it there but you almost never hear
them criticize the channel in public you
can't break ranks but brooke baldwin is
an
exception baldwin recently announced
she's leaving cnn
she's had a lot to say on her way out
turns out that the channel that lectures
you about sexism
apparently hasn't adopted the standards
they want you to follow
watch i've been anchoring
for 10 plus years the majority of that
time two hours in the afternoon and
in that time um you know the
the the most influential anchors on our
net network the highest paid are men
uh my bosses my executives are men
the the person who oversees cnn dayside
is a man and my executive producer
for 10 years is a man so i have been
surrounded
by a lot of men well that's a lot of
dudes
are you shocked cnn is awash in toxic
masculinity come on of course it
is have you seen the chris cuomo
exercise videos
look at those lats it's like mad men the
soul cycle edition
thinks some butts have been slapped in
that newsroom you're damn right baby
just like you like it not acceptable not
acceptable anymore
so how do we fix it how do we fix cnn
well it needs new leadership
obviously but it's not that simple
they're not a ton of people who can run
a declining left-wing propaganda network
you need
relevant experience to do that so here's
an idea
jeff zucker should transition it's not
hard
as cnn has told us many times if you
look like a woman
you are a woman you have all the female
intuition and
empathy that the sex is famous for
overnight the transformation is
instantaneous so jeff zucker wearing
dockers has no earthly idea what brooke
baldwin is talking about it's like she's
speaking latvian
but you put jeff zucker in a sheer black
strapless dress and he
instantly understands her maybe we'll
even rehire her
jeff zucker will as we say in the female
community finally get it
toxic masculinity solved the only
question is
will jeff sucker do this we'll see
but be warned if he doesn't transition
or if he complains about our suggesting
that he transition in any way we will
know for certain that jeff zucker
is transphobic there's nothing worse
than that even cnn's exercise videos